things seem to be very good we uh
have been doing very well with the china
virus but they've had
a pretty big spike in europe as you know
in uk in particular
and i'm sure they'll have that under
control hopefully soon
but we're in very good shape the
vaccines are coming along i just got a
report
the vaccines are coming along rapidly
therapeutics are coming along very well
and
we'll see what happens but too bad about
europe mr president
i would say on friday or saturday i'll
be announcing the pick
uh it's five women
are being looked at and vetted very
carefully
five and uh we'll make a decision
probably saturday but friday or saturday
do you plan to meet with any of them in
person
do you plan to meet with any of them in
person before you make your decision
yeah
i will when do you plan to do that
during this period of time do you think
all five
i don't know i doubt it but in person
but we'll meet with a few
probably [ __ ]
well i'd much rather have a vote before
the election
because there's a lot of work to be done
and i'd much rather have it we have
plenty of time to do it
i mean there's really a lot of times so
uh let's say i make the announcement on
saturday there's
a great deal of time before the election
that'll be up to mitch in the senate
but i'd certainly much rather have to
vote i think it sends a good signal
and it's uh solidarity and lots of other
things and
i'm just doing my constitutional
obligation i have an obligation
to do this so i would rather see it
before the election what would be
well we'll have to say i would think
that that would be very bad for them
i think their their voters the people
that voted them put them there because
of a certain ideology
or a certain feel and they don't want to
have somebody do that i think it's very
bad if they do that what would be your
concern if it happened after the
election
supposedly the last wishes of justice
were made up because it supposedly came
from a grand order yeah it just sounds
to me like it would be somebody else i
don't
i don't believe it could be it could be
and
it might not be too sir what would be
you it was just too convenient
what would be your concern if the vote
happened after election day
no concern i just think it would be
better they asked would i rather have it
i'd rather have it before the election
i think it would be better for our
country
and we will pick somebody that's
outstanding very qualified
they're all qualified but uh somebody
that it's outstanding and
i'd rather see it all take place uh
before the election so before november
3rd are you concerned if you lost the
election it would be harder to get the
person
no i don't think so no i think we're
going to win if you look at the polls
the real polls
we're doing very well we're going to
ohio tonight we're packed
we're packed everywhere so people
there's never been we've never had
spirit like we have now
even four years ago the spirit now is
greater even
than it was four tomorrow years the u.n
and did you just take it i did i just
they i just did it
my message is a strong message on china
and uh basically you'll see it you'll
see it tomorrow but i just did it a
little while ago
i i have one or two that i think are
they're all outstanding but i have one
or two that i have in mind yeah
who do you think poisoned alexi navalny
in russia
uh we'll talk about that
at another time is amy coney barrett one
of the leading contenders in your mind
she's one of the people that's very
respected but they're all respected
she's certainly one of the candidates
yes and when you go down to miami will
you meet with barbara lavilla
uh i may she's uh highly thought of
and he's got a lot of a lot of support
you know a lot of people
i'm getting a lot of phone calls from a
lot of people she has a lot of support i
i
i don't know it but i hear she's
outstanding uncertainty
and she's one of the people we're
looking at did you push the doj to name
seattle
in new york and portland anarchistic
cities well i think they are
but that's up to doj that'll be up to
that will be up to the attorney general
but
certainly they are if you look at
portland you look at what's going on
there what a mess
go ahead and we could straighten it out
all democrats all radical labs
we could straighten it out so fast go
ahead why don't we make a final decision
that's working its way through i've
given a
preliminary okay they will uh work at
two great companies oracle and
and walmart uh larry ellison's uh
you know great genius at that kind of
thing the technology is incredible
and so we can save it we'll save it
and if we can't we'll cut it off but
they have preliminary we'll see what
they can do
we have to have total security that's
the only thing very important we have to
have total security
i'll see you in ohio thank you thank you
sir
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
you